Seguro que lo habrás oído miles de veces:
el dólar es la moneda hegemónica en el mundo.
Para ese “amigo inteligente” que todos tenemos, lo que en
España llamamos el “cuñado”, la supremacía
del dólar es la
clave para entender la política mundial.
Hay una conspiración mundial para que Estados
Unidos mantenga
esa hegemonía a toda costa.
Pero… si quieres dejar a uno de estos “expertos
en geopolítica” en evidencia… solo tienes
que hacerle una
pregunta ¿Qué significa exactamente que
el dólar sea la moneda hegemónica? Es decir…
¿Qué gana Estados
Unidos con el hecho de que su divisa sea la
más utilizada en el mundo? ¿De verdad estamos
hablando de
algo tan relevante? Y lo que es más importante…
¿Qué pasaría si un día el dólar perdiera
esa hegemonía?
¿Podría reemplazarlo alguna otra moneda?
¿El euro, el Yoan Chino? Hoy vamos a responder
a todas estas
preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver un poco
de historia.
Los que lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik
ya sabéis que Argentina está en una situación
muy
delicada y necesita pedir dinero prestado
a los inversores internacionales ¿Verdad?
En estos casos, lo
normal es emitir un bono de deuda. Es decir,
un papelito que dice “si tu me das X cantidad
de dinero, yo
te la devolveré en 10 años junto a un porcentaje
de intereses”. Hasta aquí, todo bien. Pero
imagina esta
situación: nosotros le prestamos 3000 pesos
argentinos al Estado Argentino. Ahora mismo,
que estamos en
2018, esos 3000 pesos argentinos equivalen
a unos 100 dólares estadounidenses. Pero…
¿Y en el año 2028?
Es muy probable que la divisa argentina se
haya podido devaluar aún más. En otras palabras,
que para el
día en el que Argentina nos devuelva esos
3000 pesos, no nos sirva ni para comprar una
bolsa de Doritos
en el supermercado.
Por eso, los inversores internacionales, que
son muy listos, le dicen a Argentina “vamos
a ver, yo te
presto dinero, no te preocupes, pero esa deuda
me las vas a denominar en DÓLARES ESTADOUNIDENSES,
es
decir, que yo te presto 300 dólares y tu
me devolverás otros 300 dólares”. De esta
forma nos protegemos
de las posibles devaluaciones.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque no sólo
hablamos de Argentina! En realidad, la mayoría
de los países
eligen el dólar como moneda de referencia
para emitir su deuda. Y por eso, seguro que
todos habréis leído
noticias como esta en los periódicos.
EL GOBIERNO FEDERAL (Mexicano) EMITE NUEVO
BONO GLOBAL EN DÓLARES A PLAZO DE 10 AÑOS
Y como os podéis imaginar, no sólo hablamos
de Gobiernos. Por ejemplo, cuando ARAMCO,
que es la petrolera
de Arabia Saudita, vende su zumo de dinosaurio
a México, les dice “Chst! Para el carro
¿Dónde vas tu con
esos pesos mexicanos que no sé ni lo que
valen? No, no, tu me pagas en dólares, que
me dan más
confianza”.
Sí, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
casi todo el petróleo que se mueve por el
mundo, se compra en
dólares estadounidenses. Y casi toda la deuda
pública que se emite en este planeta, también.
Eso explica que el 60% de las divisas de reserva
extranjera que tienen los bancos centrales,
estén en
dólares estadounidenses. En el mundo hay
más de 1,67 billones de dólares en circulación
y más de la mitad
de estos están fuera de Estados Unidos. No
existe ninguna ley internacional que diga
que el dólar tenga
que ser la moneda de referencia. Pero sin
embargo, casi todo el mundo confía en esta
divisa para el
comercio internacional.
Pero ahora os preguntaréis ¿Y esto para
qué sirve? Es decir… ¿Qué gana Estados
Unidos con que su divisa
esté circulando por todo el planeta? Pues…
depende. Si eres una empresa o un ciudadano
particular
estadounidense, te resulta completamente irrelevante.
Es más, incluso podría ser un problema.
Ahora bien… para el Gobierno de Estados
Unidos, la hegemonía del dólar es como un
regalo caído del cielo
¿Por qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
TODOS QUIEREN DÓLARES
Os lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí, en VisualPolitik,
lo peor que le puede pasar a un país es tener
hiperinflación. Es decir, que de la noche
a la mañana, los precios de las cosas se
pongan por las nubes
¿Y por qué surgen las hiperinflaciones?
Pues, en la mayor parte de los casos, este
fenómeno ocurre cuando
un banco central se pone a imprimir billetes
como si no existiera mañana.
Pero la pregunta es ¿Por qué? Es decir ¿Por
qué se devalúa una divisa cuando imprimimos
demasiado? Para
entender esto, tenemos que pensar que la moneda
de un país es un producto más, que se rige
por los mismos
principios que el petróleo, las naranjas
o los teléfonos móviles: oferta y demanda.
Por ejemplo, la
demanda del BOLIVAR venezolano es bastante
limitada. Solo los venezolanos lo utilizan.
Así que, si el
Banco Central de Venezuela se dedica a imprimir
muchos bolívares, o dicho de otra forma,
aumentar la
oferta monetaria, es normal que el precio
baje. Es decir, que la divisa se devalúe.
Sin embargo, la demanda del dólar estadounidense
es nachovidaliana: no para de crecer. Todo
el mundo, en
todo el planeta, lo utiliza. Eso significa
que la Reserva Federal tiene un margen enorme
para poder
imprimir billetes sin que el dólar se valúe.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Para qué quiere imprimir
billetes la Reserva Federal? Vamos a poner
un ejemplo. Vamos
a imaginar que le hemos prestado 100 dólares
a la Casa Blanca. Y llega el momento de que
nos los
devuelvan. Así que llegamos al Gobierno Estadounidense
y nos dicen “¡Faltaría más! ¿Cuánto
te debo? ¿100
dólares? Sin problema! Vete un momento al
edificio de al lado, la Reserva Federal, y
te lo imprimen en el
momento”. A esta práctica la llamamos “Monetizar
deuda”. Y sí, cuando le habléis de estas
cosas a vuestro
cuñado, o a ese amigo “inteligente” que
todos tenemos, probablemente, se os quede
mirando con cara de
tonto.
Lo cierto es que esta hegemonía del dólar
permite que Estados Unidos se puede endeudar
con muchísima más
comodidad que cualquier otro país. Y por
eso, si leéis prensa económica, os podéis
encontrar con
titulares como este.
La crisis de la deuda Americana se acerca.
Los pagos de intereses llegarán al billón
de dólares anual.
¿Hasta qué punto es bueno que Estados Unidos
pueda tener tanta deuda? En este otro vídeo
os hablamos más
a fondo sobre este tema.
Pero ahora os preguntaréis… entonces ¿Estados
unidos es tan irresponsable como Venezuela
o Argentina?
¡Por supuesto que no! Veréis, todos los
bancos centrales del mundo imprimen nuevo
dinero todos los años.
Y no solo hablo de imprimir billetes sino
también de generar dinero de forma electrónica.
La diferencia
está en las proporciones.
En este gráfico podéis ver el aumento de
oferta monetaria, lo que se conoce como el
indicador M2, de la
Reserva Federal Estadounidense. Como veis
el número de dólares aumenta año tras año
¿Pero qué pasa si lo
comparamos con Argentina? Creo que ya podéis
ver la diferencia ¿Y si lo comparamos con
Venezuela? En fin,
creo que sobran las palabras ¿Verdad? En
sólo 9 años, Venezuela ha multiplicado por
100 su masa monetaria
mientras que Estados Unidos ni siquiera ha
llegado a duplicarla.
Como curiosidad, os diré que, he quitado
a propósito el año 2018 porque si no, el
gráfico se salía de la
pantalla. Este año, el Banco Central de Venezuela
ha multiplicado por más de 4000 su masa monetaria.
Y precisamente, esta es una de las razones
por las cuales el dólar estadounidenses es
la moneda más
utilizada en todo el mundo. Porque es una
de las más estables. Es decir, que mientras
otros Bancos
Centrales se dedican a imprimir dinero a diestro
y siniestro, la Reserva Federal es bastante
responsable.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando… ¿Qué
pasa con otras divisas como el Franco Suizo
o la Libra Esterlina? Si
hay una divisa estable en el mundo, ese es
el Franco Suizo ¿Verdad? ¡Pues tenéis razón!
Es más, atentos
porque esta es la parte del vídeo que os
va a sorprender: aunque dólar sea importante,
no es ni muchísimo
menos, la única divisa de reserva en el mundo.
DIVISAS PARA TODOS LOS GUSTOS
Lo hemos dicho al principio del vídeo: el
60% de las reservas de divisa extranjera que
tienen los bancos
centrales de todo el mundo están en dólares.
Dólares estadounidenses. Pero os preguntaréis
¿Y qué pasa
con el otro 40% restante?
La segunda moneda más utilizada es el EURO,
que representa un 20% de las reservas. Le
siguen la libra
esterlina y el yen japonés ¡Pero no son
las únicas! Muchos bancos centrales tienen
reservas denominadas
en dólares australianos o incluso francos
suizos. Aunque sean monedas poco comunes,
son reconocidas por
ser muy estables.
Y os preguntaréis… si lo importante de
una divisa es que sea estable… ¿Por qué
no se utiliza el franco
suizo tanto como el dólar? La respuesta es
que hay muchos menos francos suizos en el
mercado.
Pensadlo bien, Suiza tiene 8 millones y medio
de habitantes. Estados Unidos tiene 300. Eso
significa que
el Banco Nacional Suizo necesita imprimir
muchos menos billetes.
¿Recordáis que os decía que en el mundo
hay unos 1,67 billones de dólares? Pues los
francos suizos ni
siquiera llegan al billón. Es decir, que
es mucho más difícil encontrar francos para
hacer una
transacción. Por otro lado, Estados Unidos
es el mercado más grande del mundo. Eso significa
que miles de
empresas de todo el mundo venden sus productos
en este país. Imagínate que eres una empresa
mexicana y
vendes un teléfono móvil en Estados Unidos
¿Cómo te pagan? ¡Exacto! ¡Con dólares!
¿Qué haces con esos
dólares? ¡Los cambias a tu moneda local!
¿Y quién se queda con tu dinero? ¡Exacto!
El banco mexicano
donde has hecho el cambio. Es decir, que cuanto
más comercia Estados Unidos con el mundo,
más dólares
circulan por el planeta. Dicho de otra forma,
el dólar es una moneda estable, abundante
y sostenida por
la economía más grande del planeta. Hasta
hace décadas, ninguna otra divisa le hacía
competencia. Pero el
mundo está cambiando.
A estas alturas, creo que ya os podéis imaginar
lo que os voy a contar. Al principio del vídeo,
os decía
¿Es posible que el dólar pierda su hegemonía?
¿O que, al menos, deje de ser tan importante
como lo es hoy
en día? Y la respuesta es que sí…
Mientras Estados Unidos se vanagloria del
“America Primero”, el resto del mundo
mira a otro lado
Lo estamos contando todas las semanas aquí,
en VisualPolitik, Donald Trump quiere proteger
Estados Unidos
del mercado internacional. Su primer movimiento
fue cancelar los acuerdos de libre comercio
con la Unión
Europea y Asia. Después introdujo los aranceles
al acero, que han servido para que empresas
como Harley
Davidson se marchen del país. De esto, os
hemos hablado hace poco en este otro vídeo.
Trump también ha
anunciado que quiere terminar con el NAFTA-Telecan,
que es el acuerdo de libre comercio entre
Estados
Unidos, Canadá y México. En otras palabras,
que los Estados Unidos de Donald Trump quieren
aislarse del
mercado. Quieren comprar menos cosas al extranjero
¿Y eso qué significa? Que el extranjero
tendrá menos
dólares. Y a eso le tenemos que sumar noticias
como esta…
Los Bancos centrales en Europa están empezando
a reemplazar sus reservas en dólares por
yuanes chinos
O esta otra…
Rusia planea una venta de bonos denominados
en yuanes chinos ante la amenaza de sanciones
¡Pero no os emocionéis todavía! Sí, es
cierto, el YUAN chino, también conocido como
RENMINBI, era una
divisa prácticamente inexistente en el mercado
internacional. Se utilizaba únicamente dentro
de China.
Sin embargo, en los últimos años, parece
que se está empezando a tener en cuenta como
divisa de reserva.
Pero eso no significa que, de la noche a la
mañana, todos los bancos cambien dólares
por yuanes.
En realidad, hay muchas incógnitas sobre
el yuan chino. Incógnitas que vuestro amigo
listillo, vuestro
querido cuñado seguro que no conoce ¡Pero
no os precupéis porque en las próximas semanas
sacaremos una
continuación de este vídeo! Así que ya
sabéis, suscribíos a VisualPolitik. Y no
os olvidéis de darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Mientras tanto, os dejo estas preguntas ¿Creéis
que el dólar será capaz de mantener su hegemonía
en las
próximas décadas? Si no fuera así ¿Qué
otra moneda podría sustituirle? ¿El yuan,
el euro, el BitCoin?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y como siempre, si os gusta este proyecto
y queréis apoyarnos, también podéis visitar
nuestra página de
Patreon. Si habéis disfrutado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE, compartidlo con vuestros amigos,
y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.